mommy nigh this is unfounded but I did
just read a little something about how
someone's found the CCP has been funding
a lot of this and it would make so much
sense tensions between US and China yep
we're already high China wanted does not
like Trump he's ruining their economy
too in their eyes and today we've been
giving them our money basically for
years and they couldn't stop him and
it's like what would be a better time to
attack us than when we're in a pure
civil war right now I mean that's it
would I wouldn't be surprised if we go
to war with China where's this area it's
a scary time now maybe yeah what's up
with this so we're for those that are
just happening in we're currently
talking about people who believe that
China the Communist Party is trying to
manipulate the protests and all that
stuff and it's unfounded it's unfounded
um it is true however Mike Pompeo said
China has infiltrated the u.s. very very
serious like teams that are free but we
have and we have known this they've been
paying professors that's the big thing
we found them bringing in coronavirus
and how is that not we did a segment
about this like a month ago and it's
like well no China was ending it was
fluent stuff oh it was a bola it was
yeah
SARS yep so they right they were they
were bringing in corona viruses like
illegally smuggling it in yeah so we
known we've known about this there was a
DOJ document that we read it's like come
on cover this yep yeah how is that not
Mariam how do people not know about that
it's like tensions are rising now now we
see this custom customs officials seized
three hundred and fifty one thousand
dollars worth of counterfeit a $100
bills in Milwaukee what do you think
they're doing with that money that fake
money they're paying people they're
paying people with it
it doesn't cost anything it says it says
that it came from Shanghai it came from
Shanghai boom China yeah so n was headed
headed for a residence in Milwaukee hmm
who has to gain from this China they
want us weak but we don't know what
they're doing with the money for all you
know I am speculating 100
here hold on brother you know they send
drugs here to fentanyl not even not even
that designer drugs they send all of our
drugs we don't know any no no no no no
illegal drugs that they send I know I
know what you're saying but I'm telling
you we but it's also true that we may
make all of our drugs they could just
slip in our drugs excuse me but it's
like you know what I mean that what if
they really wanted it though they could
totally do that you know just put stuff
in all of our drugs that we get from
antibiotics it's but it's beyond that
man it's like well this let's let's read
about this oh yeah this money here let's
see it let's see US Customs and Border
Protection's officials seized three
hundred fifty one thousand dollars worth
of counterfeit currency at a facility in
Milwaukee on May 27th the curse the
currency was in form of 3515 $100 bills
located at the Express consignment
operations facility in Milwaukee
according to news release from the CBP
according to the CBP officials the
shipment arrived from Shanghai China and
was headed for residence in Milwaukee
the parcel was selected for examination
and when the parcel was opened officers
found what was later confirmed as
counterfeit currency the currency was
made of poor material and was missing
the required watermark it had no red and
blue embedded fibers such each bill had
the same serial number and there were
Chinese letters in the back of the bills
in red officials said
CBP officials noted counterfeit money
like this described as foreign writing
notes is a violation of federal law and
is considered contraband well obviously
these foreign writing notes were
destroyed
officials said just last year more than
a hundred million hundred million
dollars of counterfeit currency was
exchanged jeez first and foremost we may
27th why is that coming in right was
that right when everything was going
down exactly days after the right
exactly so what was it like what is the
money coming in for how much got sent in
that wasn't caught that isn't that is
exactly what mammals are my most
important thing we have no idea what
this was gonna be used for absolutely
yeah sure all speculation but that's
what I'm saying that's what
saying before everything is fishy
everything I'm reading it's like why
what to what end
there's just always this little weird
twist but this is this is fishy man this
doesn't make any sense two days after
Floyd you know got killed all let's
money let's throw in all this fake money
doesn't cost us any but it's paper or
whatever
jashin yeah it's not even good but
there's people out there they see a
briefcase filled of that go go go throw
brick and not even that not even that
here's 100 bucks bro go buy some go buy
something this that you know yeah
or how about hey triangle get whatever
you can there's some picking tables over
here maybe that video yeah that guy got
accused you know of like paying
protesters or whatever I'm using as an
example not to accuse the guy cuz I'm
not gonna want to accuse the guy but you
see these videos it's not even about
paying someone for all we know somebody
could have been given like oh yeah
here's a hundo just you know go pick up
some you know some water bottles and
then what are they used to throw cops
start fights water bottles mm-hmm so it
could be really really simple I mean
look man
yeah we're dealing with Chinese
intelligence mines China's sending fake
bills to Milwaukee crime cuz look right
now we don't know if he's even rhyming
right that's it obviously it can be as
simple as this it could be as simple as
you know if you give us $1,000 we'll
give you $3,000 in fake money and so you
can pass it off slowly and we get the
money up front to actually use as we see
fit you know through like actual
institutions laundering and stuff like
that regardless there it is wasn't
something we wasn't the cops original
reason for going after Floyd was a fake
bill yeah interesting dude 20 dollar
bill counterfeit money you're right but
we're doing a lot of speculating right
now but totally but hold on I admitted a
hundred percent this was in Milwaukee -
yeah it's not that far away from
Minneapolis it's not it's not I mean how
many hours is that it's probably like a
five-hour drive I don't think it's that
far yeah Milwaukee yeah maybe maybe
I think it's like five from Chicago I
think it's a 5-hour Drive that's just
randomly guessing again a lot of
speculation but we can't say this
counterfeit bills arrived from Shanghai
you know two days after that's weird it
wasn't I mean nah but you know you know
what man
I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't look
too much into that connection because
that you got a lot of kind of hit bills
flowing around yeah sure especially 20s
coming from China bigger yeah no that's
the bigger question why is China sending
counterfeit bills to our country now
look
because organized crime exists for sure
true I think we should take this
consider it but we got to wait for more
evidence to see where it leads us
instead of trying to connect it to
something else
definitely however in the bigger picture
it's a fact that there have been several
professors who are in on the take from
China getting paid you know and lying to
our government in exchange for money I
can only assume it's because they're
passing off our secret from our
universities to China you know China has
been stealing our intellectual property
and so David sending niner drugs so all
the people I know throughout my life who
have ever bought designer drugs all come
from China they make well yep so you
don't have designer drugs right no MDMA
no they take an illegal drug and
manipulate like one molecule so it
becomes legal right and then they send
it in it's a different string and call
it plant food or something right yeah
plant food do not eat or with bath salts
yeah that's the famous one gosh yeah
john mcafee so they're they're clearly
using subversive methods to damage us
and to harm us and I think Trump comes
along and you know he shuts that down
they don't like it so for them yeah
they're in trouble they're like Oh our
plan yeah Trump is throwing all of the
corporations that he's thrown a big huge
wrench it's called has America made in
America written on the side of it but
what about the utopian vision of a
one-world government Adam are you
honestly asking me yeah yeah yeah that's
the argument where's this vision coming
from the argument is well who's got the
vision that that that's gonna work I
don't know I don't trust her that they
know where the argument is you know
globalists are trying to create a
one-world government right I mean I'm
not saying literally everyone's argument
but this is one of the things you hear a
lot and Trump is a nationalist so he
believes in America being better and
stronger and faster and wealthier and
all the stuff and it's causing harm to
the convenient foundations of certain
high profile not argument from you
guessed it
yeah yep man I think the big the big
challenge is you know the way I've put
it is I think globalism will happen no
matter what we do well we have to
prevent is authoritarian globalism so
that's what we Sonny would do that
you don't let China take over yeah and
so I think that's what we're seeing
China's been you know right you know
they think a lot of the American
politicians who hate Trump it's not
about them like it's not about like you
know ji Jinping flying on a private jet
and landing you know a Hillary Clinton's
house or whatever are like Martha's
Vineyard and being like here's a
briefcase full of a million dollars you
know yeah it's about him saying like we
have lucrative business opportunities
for your son Joe Biden how about we
offer up a 1 billion dollar loan to your
son Joe Biden yeah and then they're like
now that we have this deal we don't want
Trump to mess it up and it's not about
some grand conspiracy it's all overt and
in-your-face we mean no Joe Biden was
doing this with this kid flying on it
was that they flew on Air Force two yeah
they did so yeah there you go man mom so
so Trump is not happy about it and there
you go you can see exactly why they
would be upset if Trump goes to war over
this I mean war figuratively not
literally right maybe even literally
yeah yeah hopefully not but the
questions of whether or not China's
trying to hurt us oh dude there's no
question no questions none none at all
that's why I see this and I'm like
they've been they've been obviously
there they're messing with us complicit
American politicians giving away our
labor and manufacturing mm-hmm then
you've got there's the constant theft of
our intellectual property just like
technology like corporate espionage the
university professors who are getting
paid to double-dip and you know give
them research projects or whatever then
you've got Mike Pompey we're talking
about the infiltration mm-hmm and now
you've got weird counterfeit bills
designer drugs dude it is probably worse
than we realize oh yeah it is that
probably freakishly worse definitely
then you take a look at it's really
funny when they talk about you know
Russian propaganda like dude arty is not
even that big like Russia today you have
any of that big Al Jazeera yeah Russia
really the views really isn't I thought
you know who do you think the
superpowers are on the planet you know
like most money you know it's like Japan
it is
higher on the list than Russia is and I
was like oh wow yeah you know that not
like oh wow
India is also yeah it's like okay how
many people are in Russia like 60
million I don't even know but the
population but it's like as far as like
GDP of the country as a whole it's like
they're not really high I think they're
like number seven or something it's like
oh okay
like all right 144 million Russians oh
there you go okay a lot bigger than ever
look then I thought yeah what do you got
oh no no I was gonna look up the
population now Russia pretty much yeah
yeah that's that's and then you got
China won something
you know 1 billion 1.3 billion or
whatever mm-hmm yeah they don't like us
they're gonna pay man they have a lot to
eat to lose through Citadis trap yeah
China is growing as a global power an
act economy and once they get close to
displacing us we are very very likely
going to see a War break out you know
which brings me to the next really fun
conspiracy theory I hear a lot and
what's this that everything we're seeing
with the rioting is actually not because
of China it's because of Trump on
purpose so we can be prepared for war
huh where are you hearing that just
stupid little posts and comments and
stuff and tweets mmm I've seen people
tweet something like this is all part of
the plan to get Americans ready for a
war with China think about it yeah I
have first kovin everyone must learn how
to bake bread in their homes you know
now they're all baking bread and they're
all starting a little gardens and it
shutters down the unnecessary parts of
the economy now they all have guns no
right then everyone but guns mm-hmm then
the riots though insured everyone went
out and got guns true and this is
basically putting people in a crisis
mode which could be bad but this is this
is the inverse of that conspiracy theory
that we've been gearing up for a war
with China so how you get your
population ready for a conflict they
need to be armed and they need to be a
bit more self-sufficient and less doughy
to major crises back to back force them
shock them give them some strife mark
them up quick and fast because wars are
coming and they got 1.3 billion people
we got 300 we got we have 1 billion less
people than China does 1 billion less
that's true so I'm not saying it's true
but I do mention this a lot to my
friends I'm like the idea
that all of this happened like the
reason why the the governor's are
allowing the protests while disallowing
the the lockdown what's the real reason
for it well in all honesty bias an inept
Atun yeah but a lot of people say it's
because they want people to be locked
down to force specific economic
self-sufficiency and they want the
protesters out to shock and scare people
into arming up becoming to a defensive
also getting out of cities you know why
cities are extremely weak points that's
true so now all the people are fleeing
cities because of both of these issues
and spreading out across the country so
it'll be a lot harder to take take out
the American population with a single
strike when everybody was living in the
eastern seaboard one multiple
independently targetable Cole twelve
warheads all the cities hit now
everybody's moved out of the cities
that's a good point yeah so at the I
guess the worst-case scenario is there
is a bit of silver lining yeah in all
the chaos I mean I think I think all the
to way people are laughing and cheering
because now the two like second
amendment is basically put on a pedestal
that's true all of these gun tote you
know gun control people from cities are
now like zip every prep route there's
just every been like everybody shifted
hard right on to a that's true so like
me as a moderate I'm like I'm getting a
second 400 until people are like I think
I should consider getting a gun for me I
mean I was down for it you know a while
ago but considering I think is happening
now you're getting the Cadillac though
apparently look I don't know man I just
blame I blink router yeah no I mean it's
awesome they apparently worked really
really hard to pull it off pretty cool
I'll make sure to like when it comes to
photo I've had many many people asking
me to get a box opening video a week I
got a do it I'm gonna do I mean people
have been asking me I love my fans you
guys are awesome out there so I got
worried we'll do another I'm gonna film
you I was I was gonna get some Ricky
Ricky old flintlock subtle shot and the
Crowder was like listen
man let me let me let me call you back
later and then I got a call like you
know come on the show and we have a
surprise for you or something
yeah all right we catch you it a rifle
and I was like okay
hey man sweet nah we definitely gotta go
to arrange your inner you were gifted a
rifle by a Viking by a Viking yeah early
appropriating plugin yeah but we
definitely ought to go to arrange oh
yeah my training I know a bunch around
here so yeah yeah I already artis sought
them out training first and foremost
take it seriously
totally yeah I've been I've been to
places where people don't respect
weapons governments don't and it's like
you don't want that stuff but yeah man
think about this milquetoast offense
sitting tim was knocked off the fence on
that issue that's true think about what
would happen now in the event of some
kind of ground incursion or some kind of
actual assault you've got a militia now
you have you you've got a gun behind
every blade of grass yeah that's true so
that's a that's a silver lining I think
I think a lot of people you know the way
conspiracy theories work is they as they
look for patterns and make assumptions
based on what they view as being you
know improbable okay so it's like what's
the likelihood that all of a sudden this
crazy right happened at a time when
we're about to go to war in China's like
about to invade India or some crazy
stuff over in Kashmir okay all this
crazy stuff doing Beach they're doing
Beach of beaching trainings apparently
really yeah and China like get their
boats going around Taiwan all is going
down and all of a sudden some riots
break out and Americans go nuts to buy
guns guns are picked off the shelf clean
yeah I think it's possible coincidence
maybe I don't I don't like drawing
conclusions not evidence so all I can
really say is hey they both happened
right but there are some people who
think there's no way that's a
coincidence
oh did you see North Korea's going on
like lockdown with South Korea oh man
it's coming yes well something's coming
I don't know where it's gonna come from
or China I really do I think honestly I
wouldn't be surprised we've been talking
about it a lot that it's been escalating
yep it's not people are not talking
about it it's like why why not how do we
not know they're they're invading right
now I'm gonna make a longshot prediction
go longshot prediction
oh goodness first I hate your longshot
predictions just no no no they're always
right that might know my predictions
about like escalating tension and like
race right stuff that I mentioned years
ago okay woods just because something
happened and I said I think this will
get worse yeah that's not a longshot
prediction that's like hey it something
happened
it literally haven't I'm not predicting
anything it happened I know and now I
think it'll happen again yeah a longshot
prediction though is really long shot
low probability I don't know I was just
thinking about this and I thought to
myself you know based on everything
we've seen based on what I've seen with
all the conspiracy theories that
everyone has and the happenstance and
the circumstance and the coincidences
and stuff I think there is a strong
possibility that in the next several
months the US government will catch a
Chinese national engaging in some kind
of subversive destructive act against
the United States yeah I don't you know
because I'm looking at history and how
we've always had these scapegoats to
direct the ire of the American people
didn't they just find that Chinese
national that's snuck into a navy boat
and was taking pictures but that's not
that's actually happen a lot okay yeah
like there have been like Chinese
nationals yeah yeah do it like welcome
to nuclear power plants and filming and
stuff yeah yeah I'm getting caught mmm
but so I'm talking about something more
severe like maybe election tampering or
you know getting caught supplying
weapons or something like something more
serious or funding a terrorist
organization without fake bills right
right or or maybe even something more
severe like actually an act as committed
people lose their lives and then they
catch a guy at the scene yeah so I think
back to history about how things played
out how people created how governments
created a pretext for war
and do you know about well no Nazi
Germany the burning of the IDA perhaps
at Rice Dog the Reichstag yeah they
found a Polish guy and I said it was him
then you also had uh it was the llll
Lemnitzer I think was his name do you
know do you know about this I'm not
familiar a shin Northwoods okay where
the joint I believe it was the Joint
Chiefs of Staff proposed having fake
Cubans attack Florida
and then Kennedy was like get out of
here no way dude we're not doing that
but the goal was to false-flag yeah now
because of the this people think you
know it happens all the time
I'm pretty sure Vietnam was a false flag
the Gulf of Tonkin incident you know
didn't really happen
so it's not really a false flag in that
regard because like we weren't actually
attacked a slide about it I don't know
we've been attacked oh we got invade so
I think I think yeah it could even be
something like that like a US aircraft
carrier gets sunk you know when it's
like trying to date it or something
yeah I mean even still going back to
this article about this this cache this
fake cash why would they put Chinese
letters on it it's kind of a giveaway
right why would they even do the average
person wouldn't know you you you think
Gladys over at Walmart who's 70 and like
taking your bills knows anything and
breathe every store I've ever walked
into and paid with a bill over 20 they
swipe it they they've got the marker the
bell but it's dumb poor people wouldn't
know and you could walk up to a dumb
poor person and say here's a
hundred-dollar bill do what I want yeah
maybe it's not to buy stuff maybe it's
to give to people and be like okay here
check us out go throw a rock through
that window yep exactly
mm-hmm yeah or or actually just show
this to him saying I got a hundred
ollars you throw a rock that window I'll
give it to you no you leave all right
you don't give him anything and dumb
people back I'll do it mm-hmm I guess we
will uh long shot prediction you know
III don't mean to say like I literally
what's gonna happen I'm just saying you
look at all these different events in
history where war you know happened mmm
and you can see they often have some so
so maybe something like that um I'm not
saying I think for sure I have no idea
what's gonna happen you know you know I
just hope everybody's got their there
you know well no as you say their guns
yeah they're sick and for hundreds and
they've uh not everyone not everyone has
that quality but no but I was gonna say
everybody has their there there was I
don't wanna say weapons necessarily but
home home protection home defense yeah
not just because of this but because of
you know riots and stuff and the
potential for conflict and it's
spreading and maybe it stops but uh yeah
food to you know yeah hey take care of
your family right thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel so
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you